one two three
that's it
[Music]
okay so if i we kind of got together at
my producer tonight we thought since you
are a dancer
um we thought that um if i gave you like
some names and
you could create some new dance crazes
oh yeah challenge accepted are you in
for it are you interested
okay yeah okay that's light you can push
that out of the way oh this
yeah it's just okay it looks heavy it's
not i can be here
okay oh you don't need okay cool he's
like i don't know what are we going to
space to be amazing so he's getting
i'm going to call out random things to
make up a dance
okay yeah no pressure don't suck
everyone's watching
um okay the plunger okay do we get music
or
oh yeah start some music yes
a plunger the plunger
[Applause]
wait what are you doing with me okay
don't worry about don't worry about it
you had me at this one oh no no you can
just do it right here
everybody stand up try that one with me
everybody do the pleasure it's the way
we have to make it right
got to hit the head i got it i got it
just get it in there
oh it's stinking that's it stinky yeah
wipe the smoke
all right great all right okay by the
way
it's all about the hips you gotta
breathe breathe okay how about
the roomba the roomba the roomba like
the vacuum
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god you're funny oh i love that
you went into it
okay the gryffindor
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the broom that's the proof that's
the secret
[Music]
you actually just recently released a
video whenever you were a teenager you
were dancing
and i think i mean you see that a couple
of this is on tv
yes we like to embarrass people oh this
is look at this
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
shows me that we could be friends
because wait what is your
so we saw your go-to dance move yes what
are your goats she's shoulders what are
you
doing oh lord i mean back in the day
it's probably about the cabbage patch
yes you know you could rock out to the
wap or something like that
you do it running man you want to see
one yes
i'll do it if you try it with me okay
still all right well now i don't have
one
yeah so there's
[Applause]
i can't
i like the cabbage patch
but you recently posted a vintage video
of you though from public school and i
wanted to take a look at this with y'all
go ahead
oh no oh my god
oh my gosh
that is so embarrassing you know
oh my god yeah yes
yes that my buddy sent that to me who's
in that my buddy eddie yamas we grew up
together that was either we couldn't
figure it out it was either like seventh
eighth or ninth grade we were in middle
school
we thought we were fly back in the day
but that was a talent show we ended up
doing what that was money do you
remember any of those movies oh my gosh
he can't do any of those movies i mean i
do them for you
no i remember well from what i saw right
there
i remember my saw right there i went i
did the ripple
[Applause]
something like that
[Applause]
remembering it now i'm remembering
okay can you show me and mike some of
your moves i want to i want to learn
what
yes i'm not going to lie
i'm i'm like freaking out a little bit
because i'm a huge fan okay
all right okay so we're going to do a
little beanies while so totally going to
kick your
tail so we're going to do the opposite
okay right so we're going to step to
you're going to step that way yes and
we're going to step this way so we're
going to go
one two three change look at that
one two three look at this okay that's
pretty good
i'll get out of my armpit shall we we're
in our family
this is called floorcraft this is called
florka
so let's do two of those okay okay guys
got that pretty
dagger i grew up in musical theater okay
so we're gonna go seven and we go arms
one
two three two hey look at
that wait a way we're not done yet we're
not done
okay and then from there i'm gonna
demonstrate with ally okay okay
she's gonna go from the last one she's
gonna step to the side
left and big oh big finish big finish
big fish big finish okay really go into
that
[Music]
so let's go from the beginning okay okay
we need applause come on guys yes
[Music]
one two three two two three nice here we
go we changed
[Applause]
it i got you i got you
are you ready let's do it
i'm a lamborghini i'm a hollywood star
i'm a little bit tipsy when i drive my
car
i'm expensive sushi i'm a cute huge
yacht
i'm a little bit single even when i'm
not
i'm a little bit i'm a little bit
i'm a little bit
like that clip was one of my favorite
moments on shit's creek
are you surprised with how popular
that's what my entire crew
loves that song they want this song
uh thank you um this song well because
you wrote it i wrote it with two of my
best buds yes who are musicians so they
did like the you know music
yes um and i wrote the lyrics and we all
secretly secretly we knew it had to be
funny
yeah but we all were like uh we want to
write a banger so
badly like it's so good how did you come
up with the dance moves because that's
what makes it epic as well
um i so i came up with the dance moves
shockingly by myself um in my trailer
about 20 minutes before we
shot and i called sarah levion
who plays twyla on the show and i was
like sarah watch this what do you think
and she was like
oh that's that's really really bad and i
was like
nice you're like nailed it i hope i
remember this oh god
gotta get my arm oh you're awesome
[Music]
are you ready let's do it what's that
i'm a lamborghini i'm a hollywood star
i'm a little bit tipsy when i drive my
car
i'm expensive sushi i'm a cute youtuber
i'm a little bit single even when i'm
not
i'm a little bit i'm a classic bronco
i'm on texas time
i'm a whole lot of tipsy when i drink
fine wine
i got like 20 jobs and i talk a lot
i'm a whole lot married my man's so hot
i'm a whole lot i'm a little bit
hide your diamonds oh my god
[Music]